depuis la disparition du créateur karl
lagerfeld en février 2019 toutes les
rumeurs les plus folles ont circulé
autour de son héritage si pendant de
nombreux mois tout le monde pensait que
c'était sa chatte choupette qui serait
l'unique héritière de l'immense fortune
du couturier
baptiste giabiconi a jeté un pavé dans
la mare en expliquant dans sept à huit
être l'un de ses sept héritiers le
premier de la liste
vous êtes le premier héritier de karl
lagerfeld oui sauf que voilà plusieurs
jours plus tard c'est une source proche
du dossier qui aurait expliqué avoir 6
que tout cela était faux tout le monde
est très en colère contre baptiste car
elle n'aurait jamais souhaité qu'on
fasse des révélations du genre c'est une
trahison
c'est n'importe quoi il n'est même pas
sur la liste des personnes convoquées
chez le notaire pour l'héritage une
version qui a beaucoup fait parler avant
d'être elle même démenti quelques jours
plus tard cette fois ci dans les
colonnes du magazine public ces
déclarations sont grossières et
mensongères sur le plateau de thé pmp
aussi de nouveaux éléments ont été
révélés par l'ancien manager de baptiste
giabiconi dans le testament j'vous l'dit
ya bien machiste numéro un et numéro 2
sébastien blondeau alors qu'en est il
vraiment de l'héritage de karl lagerfeld
on vous dit tout dans tpm people
voilà et un mot pour vous dire
effectivement la location du président
il y avait un léger décalage comme ça
c'est dit on a vérifié macro on a des
infos avec le pardon matin djabi colis
plein d'infos avec sem effectivement
voilà tout ce qui s'est résumée dedans
ne sait plus rien d'abord est-ce qu'ils
aient eu raison de parler tu as parlé
est ce que c'est le premier était pas de
premières héritiers est-ce qu'il était
fâché à la fin de sa vie avec gbe connus
ou pas on entend beaucoup de choses
bah écoutez moi la version 2 voici qu'on
a vu là sur le magnéto exactement celle
que j'ai d'un informateur très très
proches
donc d'après cet informateur oui il
serait mis à l'écart des proches et il
n'aurait pas du tout apprécié sa sortie
son interview et la sortie de ce livre
quant à l'héritage pour le moment il est
gelé il je sais pas comment il peut
exactement savoir quelle est sa place
les jeunes et il est gelé parce que il
ya beaucoup d il ya un inventaire qui
n'est pas fini d'accord il ya divers
problèmes qui font que pour le moment
l'héritage n'est pas distribuée donc il
n'est pas clair à l'heure actuelle de
savoir exactement qui va toucher quoi
quel aurait été son intérêt à lui dans
sept à huit de dire je suis le premier à
regretter je ne sais pas dans tous les
cas il est il et les derniers temps il
n'était pas accepté chez karl lagerfel
il n'était pas au mont valérien
la femme qu'elle a toujours dans mes
déjà tendues qui ont souscrit remis des
dons qu'elle a à la fin de sa vie il
était plus propre à la ferme est la gare
tous les cas il y avait aux puces ati a
fait qu il était plus présent sur les
derniers moments et qu'il n'a pas été
présent non plus non car il ya un autre
personnage clé à l'intérieur de ce
maintien de sacchi et sébastien jondeau
et donc a priori moi c'est son garde du
corps en train de m'expliquer maintenant
que tout se passe bien et qu'ils sont
copains j'ai beaucoup de mal et fois
mais rien sinon bah non mais moi c'était
c'est ça à peu près les mêmes aussi bah
oui c'est vrai c'est c'est effectivement
de bâti giabiconi la sortie qu'il a fait
là dans sept à huit et puis son livre a
été très très très mal vécu par parce
qu'il a parlé ou mal vécue parce qu'il
est dit des bêtises
les deux nés deux car la guerre faite et
qu'elle est a quand même qui était assez
discret il n'avait pas forcément envie
effectivement même si jusqu'à présent
avec sébastien jondeau ça se passait
plutôt pas mal là effectivement risque
peut-être d'avoir à nouveau
est ce qu'on appelle la chance à croix
mon à l'agent de baptiste giabiconi qui
est avec nous pardon c'est magali berda
elle est au téléphone hier
maintenant la côte et pourtant cette
émission n'est sûr utilisé mais je
t'aime nous a pas trop mais on est en
retard
qu'est ce qui t'a dit ce que ce sujet
quand même important qu est ce qu il
faut savoir que vos informateurs secrets
c'est tellement facile de parler avec
des informateurs secrets
dès que quelque chose marche fait du
bruit de maya et nouveau un temps
informateur qui sort sa part je tourne à
même de zinfos très précis
aucune précision qui n'a donné aucune
précision rentrer dans le newton ils
sont fâchés à la fin ok il n'était pas
du tout fâché moi j'ai l'information
date précise du sergent tu vas majeur
d'avion jusqu'à jeudi mais est ce que tu
dis la vérité taraba non même si dit
avec un trail de journée je suis pas je
suis pas journaliste
ah si j'ai les cartes si jusque chez une
carte de la série mais non car j'ai des
gens qui parlent alors au défi trop
facile de dire ça à des gens de passage
entre baptiste écart jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à la fin d'accord je les ai vues
de mes propres yeux donc
excuse moi je vais pas mentir je vais
pas dire quelque chose pour faire
plaisir là pour dire que tu as raison
gens tournent à tord le cou au courant
des relations qu'ils aient jamais je ne
sais pas ça que le sujet secret bastien
gens dont chanel et c'est assez vrai don
jamais tellement aimé la relation que
carl et baptiste avait et que la
relation telle qu'il a décrit dans le
livre moi j'ai lu le livre et la
déraison qui craint qu'il a écrit est
calculé pour la halle pour le vendre à
tous les magazines etc
c'est vrai mais moi je l' ai vécu tu as
dû le vivre aussi tout le monde a dû
avoir karl lagerfeld au téléphone pour
dire prenez baptiste en photo qu'est-ce
qui vous envoyer des fleurs des cas
refuser la moindre ligne sur lui et ses
et qu'ils avaient une relation amoureuse
sens en couches et âme et amoureuse
comme faisait karl avec eux c'était
quelqu'un qui l'aimé et que du coup
l'entourage était jaloux et que du coup
quand il est quand il a commencé car il
est malade être moins bien ils ont un
peu éloigné et c'est vrai qu'ils
vivaient plus à paris qu'en bâtissant là
mais l'histoire entre les deux est là et
que que quelqu'un l'avait
moore particulier pour baptiser est une
évidence c'est les gens soient jaloux du
coup aujourd'hui il jésus
les deux sébastien et carl oui ils se
font un peu mais c'était pas très amis
déjà alors il ya zéro souci en fait il
faut comprendre que baptiste était un
amour pour carlin à une prime autour de
son héritage lui c'était un travail
c'est à dire c'est qu'un gars qui
travaillaient pour lui ce n'est pas la
même chose c'était une muse c'était
c'était de l'amour c'était passionnel
voilà sept à huit ya eu une enquête et
pour votre information car la demande et
c'est lui qui a demandé à l'écrit à
baptiste décrire hiller il lui a dit tu
leur expliquera qui j'étais vraiment
motivé ça j'ai compris ce que j'aimerais
c'est pourquoi si l'héritage est gelée
et qu'il n'est pas au courant son
héritage il ya 7 et 8 mois à 5 ans a
comme sébastien qui en fait la gaffe
elle ne voulait pas et en fait je peux
dire que je connais des gens qui sont
dans son entourage et qui disent non
c'est pas vrai on est d'accord avec
baptiste g20